hello and welcome to this ha step of the
day in today's video we're gonna talk
all about speeds and feeds will show you
the path that we take to reach starting
speed and feed values that we can trust
that will work with any tool and
material combination will be using
inches in this video but we've made an
entire other video for those of you that
are using the metric system a few key
concepts a formula and we'll reach the
RPM that our program needs another quick
calculation and we'll establish our feed
rate and have you home in time for
supper as we jump into one of the
coolest concepts in CNC programming
speeds and feeds I've got a question for
you are you ready if our tractor is
moving along at an amazing 1 mile per
hour
that's 88 feet per minute which tire is
moving faster our small front tire for
our larger rear tire everything for me
begins with my setup so check this out
tightening up those tools by hand
[Music]
that's it pencils down answers I know
it's kind of a trick question it depends
on what I mean by faster if what I am
asking is how fast the tires are moving
across the surface of the ground where
the rubber meets the road then both
tires are traveling at the exact same
speed 88 surface feet per minute
see both tires travel the same distance
where it matters along the tyres edge
now if we're talking about revolutions
per minute rpm then that's a different
story
while both tires cover the same amount
of ground the smaller tire had to make
more revolutions per minute to get there
if we want to calculate how much ground
a tire will cover with each revolution
then we'll need to come up with some
kind of ratio between a tires diameter
and its circumference well it turns out
someone has already figured this out for
us and they've even given this ratio a
name pi the ratio between a circles
diameter and its circumference is pi so
no matter what diameter our tire is the
distance around the outside of that tire
where the rubber meets the road is
always 3.14 times greater this tire has
a diameter of 3.8 two inches three point
eight two times pi is 12 now this tire
come on this tire has a diameter of 40
inches 40 times pi about 126 inch
circumference okay that's great get out
of it if we were to run our tires too
fast too many surface feet per minute
they would overheat blister and fail our
end Mills work in the same way there's a
limit a maximum cutting speed that a
specific tool can go on a specific
material any faster and it begins to
overheat quickly wears out in machinist
talk if we're talking about speeds like
speeds and feeds we can be talking about
one of two different things
we're either talking about cutting speed
or spindle speed our cutting speed our
VC our surface footage per minute is the
speed our tool is turning at where the
rubber meets the road where it where the
tool meets the part and our spindle
speed is simply our revolutions per
minute our rpm now we get our cutting
speed SFM
right from our catalogs but the control
the Hosmer Sheen needs to know the RPM
value our spindle speed that's our s
code to get from here to here we're
going to use a formula and that formula
is gonna make use of pi and our tools
diameter to convert our sfm what that we
got from our catalog into a spindle
speed and RPM value now once we've got
that rpm value we can calculate our feed
rates speeds and feeds here is our
formula to calculate our rpm now I'm
gonna start using some some symbols some
notation because those are the symbols
being used by all of the tool suppliers
now and you'll need to recognize them
rpm equals cutting speed times 12 all
divided by our diameter times pi 10 is
our rpm our spindle speed the S code in
our programs this is what we're trying
to solve for VC is our cutting speed
that is our surface feet per minute D
also sometimes listed as d1 or DC is our
tool diameter this is the long version
of the formula the 12 in this formula is
there to convert feet to inches there
are 12 inches per foot we already know
what PI is now we're going to simplify
this formula by dividing 12 by PI
that gives us 3.8 to this new simple
formula is the one that we're going to
use today before we open up our catalog
and get our cutting speed before the
tractor even leaves the barn we need to
know exactly what cutting tool we're
gonna use and we need to know exactly
what material we are going to be cutting
now in the good old days all we really
needed to know was whether our mo was
high speed steel carbide P CD or CBN
those days are gone
today's tools have coatings on them that
might
they're allowable cutting speeds so we
really need to know what tool we are
working with otherwise we'll have to use
really generic values which are pretty
wimpy with our exact tool number in hand
we can go to our our tool catalog we can
download the manual for any tool
manufacturer in PDF form once that
catalog is opened up we're gonna search
for the material group section that's
going to tell us what material group our
exact material falls into our materials
are color coded
P is for Steel's Emma's for stainless
steels k is for cast irons and is for
non-ferrous metals without iron in them
like aluminum or magnesium S is for our
super alloys materials like titanium and
H is for hard cast irons or hardened
steels I am working with a 4140 steel at
least that's what we call it here in the
United States if you're in Europe and
you're using en names and numbers this
might be called 42 CR mo 4 if you're in
Japan you'll call it something different
but no matter where you are in the world
this material is gonna find itself in
the P I so material class now the number
that follows our color coded iso letter
changes between manufacturers so be
careful here kena mental calls this
material a P for Niagara and C Co may
call it a p5 Sandvik classifies it as a
P 2.1 while iskar and wid iya might call
it a p6 or a p7 same material different
tool vendor now it's important that we
get this right if you don't choose the
right material group you are gonna burn
up your tools titanium has a different
machine ability than mild steel if you
try running a drill or an end mill in
titanium at cutting speeds meant for
mild steel you are gonna melt that tool
it will overheat and fail so if you
can't find what material group your
stock
should be in then give your tooling
representative a call they would love to
hear from you
how many tooling reps out there would
love to hear from one of our viewers and
talk tools yeah that's what I thought
from the section of the manual for our
tool under the rope for our material
type we're gonna find our cutting speed
v-c
our sfm now if your manual gives you a
range like two to three hundred then
base your choice on your tool length and
your setup the more rigid the setup the
faster we can go but remember that tools
tend to live longer they have a longer
tool life when cutting speeds are slower
for my tool and material our cutting
speed is 300 sfm and I'm using a
three-quarter inch diameter tool so
we'll use 0.75 in our formula we'll do
the math and come out with an RPM value
of 1528 that's an S code of s1 five to
eight we now have a cutting speed an RPM
value that we can use without our tool
exactly we now know how fast to spin our
tool our speed the control now needs our
table feed our f-code a feed rate the
feed rate is how far the tool will
travel in one minute along the tools
centerline that inch per minute feed
rate is how far the tool will travel
along the machines axes here is our feed
rate formula for n mils we've got our
table feed equals our feed per tooth
times the number of teeth times our RPM
so what's a tooth this is a tooth it's
it's just a cutting edge along the
outside of a tool an insert is also a
tooth it's for most tools the number of
teeth matches the number of flutes this
tool has three flutes three teeth this
tools got six teeth and this one's got
four
we want our tool to take a very specific
size bite with each tooth this is our
feed per tooth in inches
just like our cutting speed the book or
PDF will give us that feed per tooth
value the catalog says that from my tool
material and type of tool path three
thousandths of an inch per tooth is a
good starting range point zero zero
three our feed per tooth times for our
number of teeth times one thousand five
hundred and twenty eight our RPM will
give us our inch per minute feed rate F
eighteen point three three six some
manuals will just give out a single feed
rate for all cutting conditions but most
will give us at least two possibilities
one for slotting and one for side
milling our AE is our width of cut
that's our step over
that's our radial depth of cut and our
AP is our axial depth of cut how deep
the tool is moving in the z-axis most
times if your slotting your bite is
going to be about 25 percent less than
if you're just side milling with the
popularity of optimized tool paths like
dynamic adaptive volume mill type high
speed machining tool pass the tool
manufacturers are getting more and more
specific with their speed and feed
recommendations so you'll often see
charts like the one we'll show you here
listing all kinds of different tool
paths you'll choose one and then match
your speed and feed to the path that
you're using now if you are dealing with
drills and not end mills our feed rate
might be listed in our catalogues as a
feed per revolution and not a feed per
tooth we just multiply the inch per
revolution chip load from the book times
our RPM to get our feed rate in inches
per minute now watch out for and know
the difference between inches per tooth
F
z which we typically use for milling
tools and interest per revolution f n
which we often use for drills here is a
completed legend and the formulas we
typically use for calculating our speeds
and feeds we've got our cutting speed
formulas spindle speeds we've got our
feed rate formulas for both n mills and
drills and we've got all of the
notations all the symbols that you're
gonna see over and over again in your
tool catalogs with all of that said
there's a big shift happening with
tooling catalogs in general a lot of
these tooling catalogs are just giving
us our feed rate and RPM values no
formulas needed you may open up your
manual and finally you don't have to do
any math at all in the past we used to
have to rely on slide rules to calculate
our RPM and feed rate
I still like these I think they're great
but today we're more likely to use an
app on our phone or a piece of software
on our computer or the speeds and feeds
calculator right on the haas control on
machines with next-gen controls you can
reach the million calculator by pressing
current commands and navigating to the
milling tab we've made some videos that
help you calculate those those tapping
feed rates will link to those in the
description well that's it let's go home
you can call your tooling rep in the
morning well thanks for letting us be a
part of your success and for watching
this hosta Pat the day
[Music]